262 passagers ont quitté hier soir la
capitale du Niger Niamey et atterrit à
1h30 ce matin à l'aéroport Charles de
Gaulle en France parmi eux une majorité
de français mais aussi quelques
ressortissants européens selon la
ministre des Affaires étrangères
Catherine Colona sur les 1200 français
enregistrés sur les listes consulaires
au Niger près de 600 manifester leur
souhaits de partir un second avion
décollera aujourd'hui à 18h de
l'aéroport civile de Niamey cette
opération d'évacuation de ses
ressortissants que Paris souhaite clore
mercredi à la mi-journée intervient une
semaine après le coup d'État contre le
président nigérien mohamed Bazoum
séquestré depuis le 28 juillet par les
forces armées du pays dirigées par le
général Aboudou Rahman tiani le mercredi
26 juillet 2023
les forces de défense et de sécurité
regroupées au sein du Conseil national
pour la sauvegarde de la patrie ont mis
fin au régime de la septième République
l'évacuation des 1500 militaires
français postés au Niger des quant à
elle pas à l'ordre du jour indiqué
l'état-major des forces armées
françaises suite à la fin de l'opération
barkhane en novembre dernier 1500
soldats ont été réaffectés dans ce pays
jusque-là alliée de la France et
stratégique pour la lutte contre le
djihadisme dans le Sahel mais l'ancienne
puissance coloniale française est
désormais visée par une hostilité
grandissante largement exploitée par la
jarte du général tihani des milliers de
personnes aux manifesté dimanche devant
l'ambassade de France à Niamey qui a été
partiellement incendié jugé responsable
de la dégradation sécuritaire dans ce
pays rongé par la pauvreté et la menace
djihadiste la présence militaire
française dans le pays est
particulièrement pointé on n'a pas le
problème avec les Français et les
résultats européens on a des problèmes
avec le gouvernements européens si ils
ont dit ils vont rapatrier leur
population ils n'ont qu'à appartient
leur armée d'abord tous les problèmes
que les gens sont en train de vivre au
Niger en Afrique
c'est la France qui est le noyau celui
qui a la passe de notre souffrance
l'écran ce sont renforcés après que le
mouvement propulschiste m62 a appelé un
rassemblement pacifique chaque jour près
de l'aéroport jusqu'au départ définitif
des forces étrangères présentes dans le
pays condamnant fermement le coup d'État
Paris exige un retour sans délai de
l'ordre constitutionnel et du président
Bazoom quiconque s'attaquerait pour
ressortissants à l'armée au diplomates
et aux emprises françaises verraient la
France répliquée de manière immédiate et
intraitable signe des crispations des
relations françaises avec l'Afrique
plusieurs médias du continent ont
interprété ce rapatriement et les
déclarations de l'Elysée comme un
préalable à une intervention militaire
de la France au Niger cette rumeur
lancée par l'agence putschis nigériane
est tenace malgré les démenties du
cadorcet les gouvernements du Burkina
Faso et du Mali voisin eux-mêmes issus
de coups d'État et proches de Moscou qui
monte en puissance dans la région ont
affirmé qu'une intervention militaire
française serait considérée comme une
déclaration de guerre les deux pays ont
également menacé de se retirer de la
CEDEAO soutenu par les Occidentaux qui a
fixé un ultimatum d'une semaine à la
gente militaire au Niger pour un retour
complet à l'ordre constitutionnel
affirmant ne pas exclure un recours à la
force nous refusons d'appliquer les
sanctions illégales illégitives et
inhumaines prises contre le peuple et
les autorités nigériennes ce mercredi
une délégation de la Cedeao s'est rendue
au Niger pour négocier avec les
putschistes